it is really great to be back here it's
been nostalgic to walk around and and
meet with people and and see all the
little things that have changed in the
years so I started at UC Berkeley in
2018 um and uh since that time I've been
doing a lot of thinking about you know
what is it that a mechanical designer
could be doing in the space of physical
interaction okay and so I've titled this
talk um robots that aren't afraid of
contact this is actually after a
workshop that I co-hosted at RSS in 2022
which is called the science of bumping
into things um and really the idea here
is that um you know I I want I want
robots that don't have to be super
delicate that we can rely on that we can
take risks with and do really cool stuff
and I do think that mechanical design is
really at the heart of that problem so I
run the embodied dexterity group that's
what it's called we call it Edge at ber
um and so as you can imagine we're
applying this to end effectors allot of
the time for dextrous manipulation um
and so for today what I'm going to do is
tell you about two specific projects
that I think are um hopefully going to
expand your thinking whether you come
from a computer science or data science
background or you come from mechanical
background um yes and here you can see a
teaser so this is a suction cup I love
suction cups they're great they don't
usually Break um and here you can see it
having this kind of interesting haptic
searching Behavior it's not Guided by
computer vision and there are no
electronics in the Cup itself and it's
very cheap and easy to make well easy is
all relative we'll get to that later but
um this is the kind of interaction that
I could think that we can use to
supplement things like computer vision
okay so you can start guessing how you
think that works so before going into
the details of those two projects I want
to start with just a little bit of my
journey starting from here at Stanford
so as Mark said I did get my start on
the ocean one project um and I built the
hands for this system um and one of the
most poignant moments of this project
was when we were getting ready for a
field Mission and Osama was like you
know that if the hands fail we can't do
nearly a fraction of what we want to do
in terms of demonstrating the whole
robot and that was terrifying as a PhD
student um but it was also true right
the hands and the contact points are the
conduits through which we interact with
the world and so we need to think very
carefully about them and we need to be
able to rely on them so what I learned
from this experience and it's stayed
with me since is that we need to
demonstrate resilience now resilience
can come in many different forms in this
case it just couldn't break but it could
also be something that's cheap or easy
to replace maybe you don't need to have
to recalibrate your system every time
you replace Hardware those sorts of
attributes so hopefully this is
something that you take away from this
talk um now the other major influence
for me was uh working under Mark kakosi
and this is my one of my favorite quotes
I use it all the time in my talks um
like the performance of sports cars uh
which ultimately is limited by the tires
on its Wheels the performance of a
robotic hand is limited by the skin on
its fingers I like this because it
Likens my work to race cars which is
super cool um but also there's more to
this quote right it's saying that you
could have the coolest engine you could
have the coolest sports car you could
possibly think of but if you have bad
tires you can't access that capability
and in the same way I'm really really
excited about the skin on our fingers
and how that allows us to really um
embody the full breadth of of um
performance that all the kinematics and
Dynamics and and data science and
everything that we do that's really the
conduit through which we do our work so
I think a lot about the mechanics of
that contact and how it interfaces with
the rest of the system and it became
clear that when we were working
underwater you know your tires have
Treads that's because your environment
can get wet and that changes your
contact and so we needed to take into
account the wetness of our environment
in underwater hands and so of course you
can add suction to an underwater uh
gripper and this helps you grab stuff
and here are two other Explorations
where we actually reverse the flow to
reduce contact in order to move this
squishy object into the hand um and then
on this side there's no signals here but
what we're doing is we're monitoring the
flow rate going through the tube and
that gives us a sense of our contact
conditions with the world so imagine
you're drinking Boba everybody loves
Boba um you can tell when one of those
tapioca balls goes into your straw
you're not looking at it you're not even
feeling it with your skin this is a
pressure and flow phenomenon okay you're
inferring what's going on through that
that's kind of what's Happening Here all
right so what I got from these
experiences are these two other
properties okay so we can actually think
about our environment and creative new
new ways like Hey we're in a fluid let's
not ignore that and actually that opens
doors to new mechanisms so let's harness
our environment in this contact regime
and then the second thing is that it's
really useful to add a sense of touch
but it doesn't always have to be hard it
doesn't always have to be a lot of
electronics it could be inherent to how
you're manipulating that contact okay so
we really want to add that sense of
touch embodied intelligence gets you a
lot of the way but um we want to have
feedback control as well okay so these
are the principles that I'm going to be
demonstrating hopefully throughout this
talk um and hopefully this talk gives
you sort of new ideas in this space this
is not meant to be a thesis of like
these are the three only principles of
robots in the real world um who aren't
afraid of contact but I think they cover
a lot so I got my start in underwater
Robotics and uh as Mark alluded to I did
continue that work in underwater systems
so here we literally designed treads for
fingertips in lubricated conditions and
found an Optimum solution which is a
little odd it's not a normal skin
geometry um in March of 2020 we were in
French Polynesia doing field testing
with this uh spine gripper as you can
imagine that uh project did not continue
after March of 2020 so it wasn't
published very much um but we we were in
the field and we've even done some fish
inspired work that Stanley Long here
contributed to it's under review right
now um and uh thinking about how we can
use the fluids around the the robot to
do fish inspired manipulation but we
evolved outside of the ocean um and so
we've also looked at the ground and how
we can understand the mechanics of this
inter interaction in systems so we
designed the first legged robot that's
able to actually pull itself its whole
body underground which takes many times
the amount of uh force that it has in
gravity and its weight we then
translated some of these modeling tools
to understand how we can drive the
wheels better of a Rover that is stuck
on the moon and actually it turns out
that you want to drive the wheels at
different speeds which is different from
on a hard material where you want them
all to go the same speed that was just
an assumption a lot of Rovers had had
previously and then we even thought
about the captin effect and how friction
interacts with cables in real world
environments okay but not as many people
work on granular Media or underwater
environments as there are people who
work in the air okay so I would say the
vast majority of roboticist especially
in academic environments are in Labs on
Earth Earth and that Earth has an
atmosphere okay so unless you're solely
working on systems for underwater or in
the vacuum of space air is the medium
that we need to think about okay and so
I'm presenting sort of the inclusion of
air in Creative new ways into our
robotic grippers um but in fact this is
not a New Concept um how do we harness
the environment how do we harness the
air around us in gripping well there's a
couple really straightforward and
important ways that we already do this
one is the suction cup so suction cups
do not work in the vacuum of space they
rely on the fact that we have a a fluid
around us and it's pressurized okay so
we need to have a pressure differential
between PA and PB in order for this
mechanism to work so this is harnessing
our environment in
contact and um these are very very
successful mechanisms um this is just a
screenshot from McMaster showing all the
different kinds of suckers that are out
there this is not a oneandone kind of
thing there's actually quite a lot of
intricate and beautiful design that's
happening in this space with single cast
rubber materials and you can even see
interesting sort of porous this like a
granola bar um objects that these are
able to grip onto now the the wide
variety that is available to us is
because we need to be able to grip onto
different types of objects and to apply
different loads to them and so that's
where we get a lot of specialization and
less generality okay so how do we
translate this to more General
applications well I would argue that we
need a sense of touch okay so if we're
going to overcome the limitations of not
being hypers specialized for one
specific object or scenario then we're
going to have to have some sort of
feedback control to actively um
compensate for that deficit and I would
say that suction cups I mean who's who
here has worked with a suction gripper
at some
point wow oh my gosh you guys got some
suction Griers in here okay they're good
stuff um so what I would say is well I
thought everybody was going to raise
their hand um but I think that one of
the reasons why these are broadly
adopted is because they inherently
demonstrate the resilience that we need
in our systems right you can just plug
one in it works if it breaks you unplug
it you plug another one in and it works
okay you don't need a PhD and robot hand
building to use one of these things um
and again we're using the environment so
that's where we leave this last
opportunity for sense of touch
so um in suction grippers this is still
U an important and hot area of research
how do we plan for and deploy our
suction grippers to grab onto let's say
objects in unstructured environments and
here's um a highly cited work from the
Amazon uh robotics Challenge and here
you can see that it's trying multiple
times to pick up this um binder it fails
and then eventually it
succeeds the way that this research is
often done is really based on computer
vision or predictive planning okay so
can we look at a scene identify what we
want to grasp and then grasp it
successfully um and then the next thing
is that there can be some feedback on
the section so you can see that it just
lifts and then goes straight back down
when it's not successful they are I do
believe using some sort of pressure
sensor to say whether it's engaged or
not but it's treated sort of as a binary
and is not used during grasping and that
means that during grasping the grasp
location is not modified so that's
that's where we come in with our smart
suction cup to say well can we use
Vision Plus tactile sensing so vision is
going to be used to choose the initial
grasp point but then haptic is used to
modify it and can we not think of Gras
success just in this binary terms but if
we're close to a successful grasp can we
use that information and move to the
right location and then finally we're
going to modifier grasp after initial
contact so I asked you earlier if
somebody uh if to think about how you
thought this works now you can see how
close you are so this is a single cast
silicone rubber structure but there are
these uh four walls or four chambers
that are inside of it and so the flow
actually breaks up goes through all four
chambers and then it comes back together
and it goes through this single let's
see this single uh suction line so the
flow goes up through all four chambers
and and then up and through here these
penetrate here at a uh pressure sensor
so there's no uh flow kind of going
through those
continuously um and each uh pressure
transducer is therefore effectively
measuring the wall pressure of this
little pipe right who whoever's taking
fluids will know that pressure is
related to flow rate okay so we're able
to get differential pressure flows
within this
cup here's another look at this so
here's that connector so all the goes up
and then this way and this is where the
flow comes in breaks up and then all
goes through here as it goes up into the
section
line um and this can be yes this can be
quite small here is the suction cup Tada
it always looks bigger when it's on the
slides um I actually think it would make
our lives easier if we made it bigger um
but they they can be quite small and
it's done in a single cast uh silicone
process um and so of course this is
flow-based so we did some preliminary
simulations to understand how the flow
would change within the cup um and so
you can see here on the top that um
we've got a leak going upward so imagine
you're on a PCB with a little via that's
breaking your seal you're going to see
that flow goes up through this chamber
and then uh and then we're going to get
a a differential pressure between the
two sides and you can have other
scenarios as well but basically you're
able to compare the different channels
to each other to get that
information okay so here's what it looks
like when you're pulling that suction
cup off of an ftir surface where the
bright is uh the contact UM and the dark
is no contact um and so you can see that
over a very short period of time you get
these kind of catastrophic popping or or
breaking off um failures and what's
happening here is that you actually have
a leak Point such that the air shoots
across and so we would expect that
maximum flow would be in chamber four
and you can see that the purple chamber
four is lower than these other Chambers
and so is getting affected more than the
others so we're seeing sort of the
physical Trends we would expect um and
that's what that looks like with the air
shooting
across so with that we were like okay
this is some cool data we've got
something physical that's happening what
do we do with it so we went across the
hall to Ken Goldberg and said hey what
can we do with this data and he was like
well let's let's do a predictive model
okay so let's try to actually um feel
what's happening inside of the cup to
say when and at what edge of the cup the
failure is going to occur um and we
found that we were able to somewhat do a
predictive uh model with just the
suction cup Al then it performed very
similarly to a load cell um but it was
still really interesting and a good
confirmation that we were able to get
some predictions so that's where we
pretty much left the like failure
prediction I think there's more to do
there um so you could imagine as you're
picking up this object feeling that it's
torquing and then how it's moving and
then actually adjusting your grasp on
the
fly but what I'm really interested is
that that old question I brought up so
how do we actually adjust our grasp
after we're making contact and I think
one of the reasons why there are so many
different suction cups is because of the
different materials so you have the
granola bar you have smooth surfaces um
what if you can't perceive the texture
that's going to make or break your
suction grasp so we for now on I'm going
to be focusing mostly on texture so in
this video here what you can see is that
the suction cup is sliding across a
rough um piece of acrylic and then a
smooth piece of acrylic and when we
first come onto to the surface we get
this intermediate so this is just the
average of all the chambers and then we
get a full engagement reading when it
goes onto the smooth so this is how
we're getting these like Rich
intermediate
values okay so we're going to use that
information to do this so you can see
that the cup um is actually Edge
following it'll show again so we start
at this point that's um computed by
vision and then we get this interesting
Edge following behavior and then it
ultim Ely will grasp on top of an
integrated circuit and resistors and
everything so it's a a bumpy surface but
it's able to find just the right
location to grasp this successfully so
what's the controller how are we
actually doing this okay remember I told
you we're not using vision and we're
just using those four pressure
sensors it's actually shockingly
simple um so what we have is uh right
here I've labeled sort of the four
cardinal directions
we subtract the ones that are opposite
from each other so I can say left or
right which one has more suction
engagement okay this one does go this
way that's essentially that's it and
then we do it in two directions okay um
so that's what this is doing is is just
adding those together we actually do
take a unit Vector that's why the the um
motion is just constant speed um I is
just not shown here um and then you can
also do a very similar thing using
rotation so similarly Left Right which
which one's better this one's better go
towards or in that case go this way so
that this one comes into contact better
so you can do this in those two
different
dimensions and this is what it looks
like so we also added a scaling Factor
Alpha um to scale how much we rotate
versus how much we translate so Alpha
equals z is with rotation off so only
sliding and then one is just rotation
about an approximate contact point and
you can then change Alpha I believe this
is Alpha 0. five but I I don't exactly
remember but you can see that it's both
translating and rotating um and again
only using these four pressure sensors
it successfully grasps I will also note
that we're using the unit Vector defined
by these four readings we don't
calibrate it we just literally say like
what is your pressure we don't need to
like zero things or do anything fancy
just because we're basically the way
that we're using the
data okay so we wanted to see if this
actually helps right so if we go back to
that binp picking um challenge let's say
we have some algorithm that selects our
initial Gras Point what we're going to
do is we're going to use that algorithm
we actually got a version of Dex net
from Ken Goldberg we did not retrain it
we just changed the robot arm and the
gripper and and the camera and then just
applied it so you can you know we expect
there to be some error um so it's going
to find the best grass point that it
thinks we should go for we're then going
to go there and then do sort of an
iterative search process for a certain
amount of time if the time passes and we
haven't succeeded we fail if we have
succeeded at any point meaning that we
detect that our overall pressure
magnitude is high enough to indicate
that we're fully sealed then we're
successful or we try to move
it um and this is what this looks like
this is real time it's not sped up or
anything um so we look at that point we
approach the object this is kind of
subtle but we come in and it's going to
start moving because it does not detect
a successful grip and so it's going to
move until it detects that it's
successful and then it's going to pick
up the object and move
it so would that grasp have been
successful without haptic search no okay
so that's what allowed it to be
successful um and so we wanted to
challenge this again so we're we're
setting this up for vision to fail like
I know that and there are going to be
cases where if vision is perfect you
don't need the sense of touch but we
want to challenge the system right we
want to find the the role that tactile
sensing has um and so we didn't go with
basic or typical objects we chose
adversarial objects which in this
publication is defined as with few
available suction grasp points meaning I
give you this object most of the surface
would not be successful based on suction
gripping maybe it's porous or too bumpy
but there's some places to grasp so the
question is can we find
them and they could also be black or
shiny or transparent or whatever feature
makes it difficult to
perceive so here are the results this is
is the um just the GQ CNN predictive
location and you can see that this is in
fact a very difficult task so we only
get up to about 25% of the objects
successfully gripped and we're allowing
it to go up to 50 total trials each one
of these lines is one uh binp picking
trial and then the solid line is the um
the average our best Alpha which was
0.25 which means more lateral and a
little bit of rotation um was able to
get us up to in the best case scenario
about 75% success in the worst you know
it's it was still about the same as
before but on average we got a much
better Improvement and then just to make
sure that just randomly moving around
the bin wasn't helping we did a random
search so this is just coming into that
point and then randomly moving around to
see if we can get a better spot and you
can see that it's not all that much
better than this one
was okay so hopefully what I've shown
you is that you can start to implement a
sense of touch in a way that shouldn't
compromise your system mechanically and
can give you some information that can
make manipulation more successful but
this is really just a start so this is
the invention of the technology but that
leaves a lot to do in terms of how we
actually control the system so here I'm
going to show you some failures um which
is usually a good thing to do so one is
oscillation meaning we're at a point
where if I go left or right I keep
figuring out that I need to go back the
other way CU I'm at a local Optimum but
it's not enough to actually grip so I'm
never going to find a better location
another one here is I'm literally in
contact with the object but it's so
porous that I don't get any meaningful
change in my pressure or the pressure
change is the same in all directions and
then finally um the pushing uh issue
which is I'm trying to slide my gripper
across something and this is sticky
silicone and so it just moves the object
so there's no relative uh position
change so I think that this is kind of
an interesting place place to start
thinking about other types of
controllers or designs um for a
conference paper we recently looked at
this last one to see if we could improve
this through literally just picking up
our gripper so if you um still use the
haptic information but then instead of
sliding you just lift it every time you
take a step um the idea is that you can
uh overcome this issue um now the
question was though as you're touching
and interacting with the object you
might move it a little bit so how useful
is it really um when we wanted to try
and apply this to uh PCB uh recycling
handling on uh conveyor
lines so here it's not moving it's not
on a conveyor yet but you can see that
our haptic regrasp gets to where it
needs to go fairly quickly and a random
search may or may
not
okay um and so here uh we're calling
these level two level two what we mean
is that there are intact uh integrated
circuits and it is quite bumpy but it's
not so bumpy with like large connectors
that you would harm your suction cup or
like tear it in some way if you push too
hard um level one would be it's
pre-processed and so all of the IC have
been stripped off and those are just
much easier to grip and so these ones
had the larger effect um where you uh
when you just have random search um you
takes a lot of jumps to get a little bit
of benefit um but with the htic search
you get a lot of benefit within just a
couple jumps and successfully
grip um and so here is the
first attempt on a conveyor system as
you can see you do get some movement of
the PCB because they're not perfectly
coordinated um between the conveyor and
the arm but we do find that despite this
and in a very simple um Vision based
like center locator um where we are able
to improve grasping on on the next
attempt and we can improve it um just by
trying again uh quite a bit now we
didn't find that the effect of haptics
versus random was smaller because
because we're moving the object so the
htic search is going to respond in a way
that is seemingly more random um and so
this is where I think there's an
opportunity to bring computer vision to
then adjust for object movement at the
same time all right this is under review
so hopefully we'll find out soon sooner
or later whether it's accepted okay so
I'm finishing up on this project now um
where I think I just wanted to like
pitch this I think I've got a bunch of
students here who are hopefully some of
which doing a robot manipulation maybe
some of you will get more into suction
cups but I'm like I'm right across the
bay and I'm ready to see this technology
translate okay so it is still in its
prototyping phase it may still tear it
may still break but um I would really
love to work with researchers especially
in um computer vision labs in Labs that
are more cs-based to see if we can work
together to make this the next like gel
site right everybody uses gel site well
could this be the gel site of suction
cups that's kind of my I hope so if you
want to work with me on that um please
reach
out okay so I'm going to transition now
to another tactile sensing technology
and I want to pause just to talk a
little bit more in depth about sensor
integration into um soft structures uh
because a lot of hands are soft so what
I'm going to do is plot uh a couple
different just example Technologies and
what I want to show you is the distance
from the contact to the transducer so
the transducer is the element that is
translated your physical um stimulus to
electrical signals so this is usually
where you have the introduction of
electronics as well as some need to have
batteries or Wireless communication or
wires you know and so that to me is
where a lot of potential failure points
emerge wires they're the
worst okay so starting at the closest
side you have a lot of Technologies got
capacitive um here we've got a force
sensitive resistor we've also got some
some really cool sort of like fluid
Channel type Technologies um that are
integrated directly into the gripper
itself and if we move a little bit
farther um you start to get some
interesting new technologies well I
think they're new um but they're let's
just say they're less common but they've
been around for a while um but acoustic
right so you can use Acoustics within
structures um to understand sort of
where contact is and get your transducer
just a little bit farther away from that
contact point and then Vision we've got
gel which could be centimeters away um
and people are working to move it
farther and farther away from that
contact point for
resiliency and then I've even showed you
today an example of a connected um
device where the transducer with flow
can be very far away but it's still sort
of like through these channels and tubes
and some other people have done various
pressure fluids and
stuff okay now the last category the one
that's the farthest away is where you
basically are transmitting the
information through air okay so you
could do this with site you just have a
camera and you're looking at your
manipulation you can infer things about
contact and same with sound you can
listen to the contacts as they're
happening and infer what's going on and
those are great because you just need a
camera or a microphone anybody can do
that
right um and so we can bridge this
entire spectrum and while it's not a
hard and fast rule I would generally say
that ease of adoption and resilience
tends to get better as you move farther
and farther away from the contact point
but there is this issue that I see where
the reason why we want tactile sensors
closer to the contact is so that we can
measure things directly like force and
pressure right that's that's physically
relevant versus um on this side you have
to just infer what's going on it's just
a a different type of interpretation
problem um but on this side you need to
be physically connected you need tubes
or wires or something and on this side
you get the benefit of not so what I
want to do is do both okay so I want a
tactile sensor that's measuring
something like normal force right
something I want um but have it not be
physically
connected so let's think about air
air we can use it as a sensing medium
right that's what I've shown you already
as flows going into and out of our
system we can measure how that action is
happening but flow is also an actuator
okay so think of a flute I think a flute
is a beautiful touch sensor right you
put air over this part so you're
actuating it when I say actuation I mean
vibrations okay and then you change the
contact state of this device and it
makes beautiful different frequencies so
our measurement is frequency we can do
that using just a simple microphone and
guess what you could have a whole
Orchestra of flutes playing all sorts of
different notes and you can detect those
again with a single microphone so this
is this is the kind of of sort of
transmission of information that I'd
like to
have okay so here's our
[Music]
flute and this is where it gets a little
more interesting
[Music]
okay so hopefully that reminds you of
childhood and playing with toy trains or
whatever you did um with with musical
instruments um but we're what we're
calling this is aous Tac okay so it's
acoustic based tactile sensing where
when I say not connected I do I do
acknowledge that there is a pump right
so the actu is connected but the sensing
itself is not okay so it's going through
the air as sound um okay and so here we
have what's a tin whistle which is
probably closest to what I just showed
you um where the red part is called the
fipple this is the knife edge where the
flow is going to go across and actually
oscillate against that knife edge to
create the vibrations and then we've got
the resonant tube which kind of
manipulates the frequency in different
ways based on length and holes and so
forth so this is what one of the tox or
tactile pixels looks like where we have
a 3D printed structure with the knife
edge and with part of the uh the
resonant tube here and then this is what
that would look like from the top and
then from the
side of course it makes
sound um and so how does this work well
just to give you some intuition what we
have is the function of frequency
getting omitted is uh inversely related
to the length Okay so we have this
compliant cap at the end and as we apply
a force it will compress which will
reduce the effective length and
therefore it's going to increase the
frequency okay so that's it and this is
assuming very simple harmonics it's more
just for understanding not necessarily
like a true model um okay so we did some
testing of this just to calibrate and
understand um and so this is what
generally the signals will look like so
um we have the raw signal we then do a
spectrogram in this case we're just
looking for the brightest Point um and
so that's how we get a single line from
the
data so this is what it looks like when
you're looking at all four of them so
what we've done is we've chosen four
different lengths of tube such that
they're in different frequency ranges
and this would be a very simple way to
get multiple measures at the same time
without them overlapping um and when you
zoom into one of them this is what the
signal looks like as we apply a force um
and the frequency this is not a great
signal okay it's it's goes up and down
how do you know what your Force actually
is if you get a reading especially in
this lower region
okay so what we think is actually going
on and I would say this is just a
hypothesis we have not proven this but
what's happening is you have this
flexible Dome and you can actually feel
when it's when it's uh whistling without
contact and you gently touch the top you
can feel little vibrations so it's not a
perfectly closed system like this would
indicate it might be some intermediate
like semiopen sort of approximation so
it's it's um transitioning from 2 L to 4
L and so that's why we would get this up
and down uh back and forth at initial
contact so we're designers we're like
well let's just design it out let's take
it take it away so first we're going to
change thickness if you have a thicker
cap might be stiffer might have less of
an issue also let's add a hole this one
is a little less intuitive but um when
you add when you have an open system you
might need a different amount of flow to
get it to resonate so what we're
actually doing is changing how much flow
we need to resonate it in when we're
contacting it or not and that'll make
sense later and then finally we just
added Mass so if you add Mass it'll be
closer to closed this is actually my
personal favorite it works really well
um but I'm not going to show you the
results just know that it works okay so
and then there's going to be a key up
there as to the different properties and
um that we're
testing okay so let's look at one
without a hole and one with a hole you
can see they have very similar trends
when contact is made with a little bit
of shi
um for whatever nonidealities
but when you look at the amplitude of
this signal you can see that the one
with the hole starts very quiet and then
gets loud versus the one that's always
uh closed um is always very
loud and so you could create an
amplitude threshold to then filter out
when you're not making contact and get a
lovely uh uh non um or a lovely
monotonic signal um using that
process um and so of course if you
change the thickness you can get
different sorts of sensitivities um and
then uh you might need to have different
thresholding based on the size of the
hole and in fact if you want to measure
really light forces you want to be more
open without contact so a larger hole
okay so this hole is what makes us such
that we have signals that are off when
there's no contact being
made okay so this is just sort of like a
creative explor ation of this possible
space um but what we're finding is that
this could be applied in many different
ways so if we think of this again and
now put it on a finger why not um so now
we have a resonant tube which is this
silicone structure which is now pasted
onto the side of the
finger like so make sound and this is
what it's going to look like when we
stretch it so when you stretch it the
frequency goes down as you might expect
um and this is non-hysteretic and has a
nice nice clean signal so why don't we
uh put this back on the finger and as we
bend the finger the tube is going to get
stretched a little bit because it's not
right on the the right bending axis and
so we can get a fairly good measure of
curvature again without contact so it
would be harder to do with contact UM
and then for the fun of it let's put a
hole in here and let's see what happens
you can get pre-touch so before you
actually touch the surface you start to
get some signals um before contact
occurs which is kind of cool but you
also just know whether you're in contact
or
not um and then here is what it would
look like in a robotic gripper where on
the top you have pose is actually just
in one finger and then contact is in the
other finger um and so here you can see
that the finger curls and we get contact
some interesting things happening with
contact but then you can see when it
gets lost when the object gets pulled
out of the hand but curvature is still
uh
measuring okay so this was sort of just
a a second exploration of how we could
harness air um in a way that is just not
typical okay so thinking of it not just
as you know a thing that we have to deal
with or a thing that can help us grip
harder or a thing to help us sense but
actually to now communicate information
and I find this fascinating because this
is how we communicate information I'm
literally using my lungs to like push
air through my vocal cords and yell at
you guys about how to do this so uh I
think it's kind of a just fun a fun
thing that emerged
unexpectedly now there is something that
we need to talk about so you might just
be careful there's some sound oh wait
okay so at first it was really loud
we're going down the hall and we're
going to we're going to turn the corner
you can still tell the contact state of
your robot okay so this is great if you
want to let's say go to um a place that
has a different atmosphere maybe you
want this to be on Mars
well sound attenuates a lot faster in
that environment and so you're going to
have to be very loud to make this work
um but this is a little bit of an issue
you know we did this at night we wore
ear protection this is not safe around
people in a regular basis um and it's
going to be something that you can tune
based on your environment whether it's
loud or quiet or so forth and so there
is sort of some questions as to how do
you process this data in more complex
soundscapes um and how do you tune the
design accordingly um for human safety
though I do have a student J who is
working on the ultrasonic version so
hopefully it's something that people can
have in their own homes and totally
annoy their
pets
okay so um I think this is just my like
last food for thought you know when I
watch Star Wars or I see these movies
where the robots literally have like a
beep bo robot language there's a part of
me that wonders like that should have
contact information like that should be
based on the physical state of that
robot it's not for people this is is a
language for robots maybe between
different parts of the body maybe I have
a microphone on my head and I've got air
going to my fingers and I know what my
contact is because I'm communicating
that so just food for thought and think
about what robot language we should be
having in our
systems okay so to conclude um these are
the tenants that I've been really
fascinated with we want to make sure
that we're harnessing the environment
maybe in ways that you haven't always
thought about so think about the air
that you're in and how this can
influence your designs
we need to demonstrate resilience at the
end of the day robots are not going to
make an impact unless people can rely on
them and I feel very strongly about that
and that's why we've done this
exploration of sort of these really
passive interesting uh structures and
then finally though just because
embodying intelligence morphological
computation is great doesn't mean that
we shouldn't have active sensing so I
think it would be a mistake to to just
ignore that all together it might not
every sensing modality might not make
sense in every scenario but I think it
would be a little bit a silly to just
ignore it all
together um and then I want to thank and
acknowledge the incredible work of the
students in the lab um and actually this
I couldn't go to bars this year but this
warmed my heart to see Mark and Paul
with my students and my students came
back were like oh I got to meet them so
that was really fun um and then I just
want to acknowledge that uh the suction
cup work is funded by the Hong Kong
Center for Logistics robotics um and the
two students who are currently in my lab
working on this are Jung pei and
Sebastian if you're interested in
suction cups reach out um Monica Lee did
the sound based sort of flow-based
sensors or um acoustic sensors she's now
a postto with Rebecca Kramer um doing
some super super cool stuff and then T
mha who you saw throughout both projects
is now a faculty member at UC Santa Cruz
so if you want to do cool tactile
sensing definitely check out his
stuff and then um I had I really
seriously considered giving a whole talk
on Human Assistance I decided against it
because I feel like I need just like one
more year and then I'll be ready to give
the whole talk it's our newest set of
projects and it also started during the
pandemic and with human subject studies
just a little slow but we're doing some
really cool stuff on how do you actually
get a person and a human to share the
responsibility of grasping and how does
that influence their sense of agency as
well as their performance um so if
you're if you're in that space please
check out our website and I'm happy to
to tell you all about it so with that um
I'll go ahead and conclude here and take
any
[Applause]
questions have you guys looked into
multiple suction cups all that have you
know like the HAC sensing and then could
they together figure out the best way to
pick up something so the question was an
array of suction cups with this kind of
Technology um we have thought about it
we have not done the work um so I think
it's a great idea um you could imagine
even just each suction cup having one
pressure sensor and then when you look
at the array of suction cups and
actually I think Hardware wise you don't
have to then produce a suction cup you
just need the hardware to integrate the
pressure sensor um into your array um
pressure sensors are not like the
cheapest things it's like tens of
dollars per pressure sensor so but
that's I mean as compared to a lot of
robotic systems that's fairly cheap so I
think you're on to a good idea to apply
uh pressure sensing in this more analog
regime to uh aray yes I do think that
there is some interesting interaction
between the chambers when they are
physically coupled onto a single
pressure line so I don't know if it
would be um like I'd have to I'd have to
look at those signals to say what you
could do with it
yeah how well does this like acoustic
sensing work in Extremely Loud Like
noisy environments yes so um I don't
know if the questions are gotten on the
microphone but the question was uh what
about the Acoustics and Loud
environments um I think this is
something you would have to uh design
for the application so you could
probably measure like the ambient sounds
of a factory floor and there might be
certain regimes of uh frequency that are
kind of available to you um or you're
able to um make it loud enough and there
there's not a safety risk right so I
wouldn't say it's like
plug it into every scenario kind of
thing but I think if you're loud enough
you can probably do whatever you want
um but yeah it's a good
question um yeah thank you for the talk
interesting um for the suction cups I
guess how when you're translating to
like the real world how much does like
dust and dirt like affect the success
rate for Section cups yes so dust and
dirt is is going to be a problem for
most section cups right um but they are
used in various messy wet environments
so there must be some sort of mechanism
or cleaning or filtering that that is
already available so it's a great
question to to just know what's
available now in Industry um you are
right though that it could additionally
clog the sensing mechanism right so we
have these more intricate internal
features what if over time one of the
chambers starts to get more and more
clogged and then we start to get biased
in One Direction um amazing question I
don't have the answer to that I I do
think you know um if if we were really
serious about translating this like as a
as a startup or something like that we
would have to choose a specific
application test it see how it failed
and and I think you just hit upon one
potential failure point for
commercialization um but likely has
Solutions based on the application at
hand when you were developing the
acoustic session cups did you ever make
any
songs yeah I've asked a student to make
like a cool sound ball thing that you
could like press and the the problem is
that um this is an analog um it's
changing gradually as you press more or
less a flute doesn't do that you press
it down it makes one frequency you
release it it play makes another which
gives you the ability to make chords
that sound very nice this system is
going to be inherently discordant
because you're you've got let's say
you've got a chord and then you change
all the the things just a little bit
like one's a little sharp one's a little
flat it's just going to sound awful um
but I think that potentially you could
start to play with the human interaction
I I think I think there's a lot of
potential because we share that hearing
that you could think about how people
perceive this this information and and
if there are more positive or more
negative experiences I think that'd be
really fun to
study we did we did think about doing
more like discreet signaling but then
you kind of tend to introduce historis
into the systems like if you have
something that you have to pluck that
means you need to push a certain
distance and then you get the sound but
then you have to kind of reset it just
was a little more of an interesting
design
problem uh what are the challenges to
these suction cups uh when you are uh
gripping sharp objects yes yeah so I
think I'm going to have the same
question as before with the clogging
there's got to be suction cups that are
meant for sharper more abrasive surfaces
right so one question I would have is
how do they deal with that we have not
explicitly dealt with that ourselves and
so the rubber that we're choosing may or
may not be appropriate also we're
introducing some finer features inside
that might just be more sensitive to
potential tearing um so yeah I think I
think it's not a neutral like I kind of
I played it as a neutral like we haven't
changed the resilience at all that's not
true um we have but but I think we'd
have to do a little bit more to
understand that um and I think those
kinds of problems will emerge when
people start using them for hundreds or
thousands of Cycles or using them in
particular scenarios um so that's a good
question um I just have a um question
related to the like soft interfaces you
use like when you're choosing the
material um specifically like you want
these to be the
to have the UST do your looking for and
also like not be too sensitive to like
humidity level for example and like
temperature like some of these could be
uh could change the elasticity of the
material significantly right are the
like decisions M
decisions yeah so you're asking a
question that a lot of soft roboticists
tend to ignore which is um you know soft
materials are going to be sensitive to
fatigue to sunlight to temperature to a
lot of things right and we tend to say
well it's soft so we can run into
something and it'll be fine right that's
our definition that sort of short-term
Impact Physical blunt impact is what we
typically term as resilience um but if
you leave it out in the sun for a couple
days that might change right and so um I
think that there are real Serious
Materials questions that need to emerge
when we're making any soft robotic
structure now when we're relying on that
soft robot structure for sensation as
well um it's going to be double fold
right and then we need to understand how
that influences the readings um but I
would say that on the spectrum of of
resilience in tactile sensors I would
bet my money on something that's just a
soft structure as compared to something
that then also has Electronics or other
parts sort of integrated with more um
potential areas for for uh strain
failure um so yeah you're you're asking
a really good question I don't have the
answer to but I think it is something a
lot of people gloss
over we take maybe one more and then I'm
sorry we probably have to move out to
the patio because there's another course
here at
1:30 okay or maybe come online
or I'm a robot and I work in a gym and I
want to I want to pick up a dumb dog
right okay now if I have one of those
suction cups and I pick up like only one
side of the dumbbell the dumbbell is
going to want to like Snap off right M
how do you do you take into account like
any like the center of gravity of
objects or are you just picking up
objects that are so light that it
doesn't really matter do you envision my
my gym robot or yeah so we are currently
using a form of um like algorithm that
does not take into account center of
gravity so um they are light enough
usually that it won't fail based on sort
of the torque due to gravity if I was
making a a robot for lifting a dumbbell
I'm not even sure I would necessarily
assume a suction cup is the right
solution um I think that in that case
sort of mechanical like instead of
relying on the air pressure you might
want inner loocking in some interesting
way with Fingers um so I I like the
posing of like let's look at a specific
scenario and think through what are the
most important properties for design and
selection of system I think that's what
I'm really hearing I think this smart
section cup will make sense a lot of
times in certain scenarios and it won't
make sense in others um so it's more
generalized than any section cup but not
quite as generalized as as any task yeah
good question thank you all right thank
you so much everyone this was a
[Applause]
pleasure